and here's the truth
the former president of the united
states of america
has created and spread a web of lies
about the 2020 election
he's done so because he values power
over principle
because he sees his own interest
as more important than his country's
interest than america's interest
and because his bruised ego
matters more to him than our democracy
or our constitution
he can't accept he lost
even though that's what 93 united states
senators
his own attorney general
his own vice president
governors and state officials in every
battleground state
have all said he lost
that's what 81 million of you did as you
voted for a new way forward
has done what no president
in american history the history of this
country has ever ever done he refused to
accept the results of an election
and the will of the american people
well some courageous men and women in
the republican party are standing
against it
trying to uphold the principle of that
party
too many others are transforming that
party into something else
they seem no longer to want to be the
party the party of lincoln
eisenhower reagan the bushes
but whatever my other disagreements are
with republicans who support the rule of
law and not the rule of a single man i
will always seek to work together with
them
to find shared solutions where possible
because if we have a shared belief in
democracy then anything is possible
anything